so christine we're getting back out
there you're doing people's hair for
events again what are some of the styles
that you expect to see trending this
fall season well 90s big blowout hair is
back girl okay we want those bouncy ends
we want the voluminous texture i want to
go to every party i can this season
honestly the holidays are coming up so
when you're putting your hair through
all that do you have any tips things
that your clients do to make sure your
hair is in good condition yeah hair oils
hair masks regular trims i also think
that if you can find a tool that really
cuts down your dry time is gentler on
your hair has heat you know controls
that's those are the game changers
we want everyone to get there with great
hair so we teamed up with christine
simons and hot tools to help you get a
salon quality blowout from home so tell
me what you did today take me through
the look we used the hot tools pro
signature volumizer you get salon
quality results in up to half the time
and in one easy step and your results is
just salon quality shiny effortless hair
what do you love about this tool well
it's one tool with three different
detachable brush heads you can pop the
heads off you can store it really easily
the style options are endless
[Music]